et si cornerback j'ai un problème
on a tenté de me tuer je suis juste un
analyste j'ai fait que trois semaines à
la ferme cornerback oui
je dois aller à moscou pourquoi tu veux
pas que je vienne parce que je vais
passer mon temps à bosser
nous américains vous croyez francs vous
êtes peut-être justement les levées ou
vous susceptible
écrivez moi votre scénario catastrophe
on sera balayée on ne verra rien venir
et oui voilà ça fait trois ans du mandat
non mais non voyons voulu si une petite
minute
non c'est de la géopolitique pas de la
thérapie de couple qu'est-ce qui se
passe
parfois c'est de nos proches
qu'il faut se méfier le plus
il y à un risque réel que nous n'en
sortirons pas du temps